hi everyone its Lauren and you are in my
house Brian came all the way over here
to film me by myself he doesn't even
want to be in a video with me probably
because he got here early and I just got
back from kungfu and I didn't have time
to shower so I hope I'm not really
smelly sorry anyway we are gonna watch a
trailer for the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles which is exciting because even
though the first trailer came out a
really long time ago I still haven't
seen any of them and I hear that the
turtles looked really flippin awesome I
have an older brother so when I was
little I watched everything he watched
and that included Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles so I was a fan I guess I didn't
really get to choose what we watch
that's why I watched Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles an x-men that's why I like
x-men also we are gonna watch it and I'm
gonna react to it cuz that's what we do
on this channel he's ready for this also
ryan's laptop is perched precariously on
like 15 books and i feel like i'm gonna
knock it over
so if that happens well that really
sucks for him it's a Nickelodeon movie i
actually know zero things about this
movie so far i mean before that
so Megan Fox go oh wow they look like
mutant turtles
whoa shredder holy [ __ ] oh my god
Wow it was fun effects going on also
like Megan Fox
no they're Turtles they're ninjas okay
so I like kind of had high hopes for
that movie because I used to think
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles were really
cool when I was little and not that this
like it's a Michael Bay movie so all the
effects look really awesome like I mean
it looks it looks kind of silly I don't
have any other words that I can describe
this I'd silly but I don't think
shredder looks to have an awesome his
armor and like knives that he's throwing
it's like Ching and it actually reminded
me of Wolverine a little bit the Turtles
look like kind of weird and also nobody
said cowabunga in the trailer which was
disappointing and I guess that what
Megan Fox is a reporter and she's like
chases them down and finds them or
something I don't know I don't really
remember what the story was about there
was that like one reporter girl right
April thank you I had to ask Ryan
because I couldn't remember is that who
Megan Fox's Ling yes oh I don't see that
I don't remember April O'Neill being
like Megan Fox but okay Michael Bay
likes no Megan Fox no movies because
she's really hot people will watch it
and also I'm sure this is a movie
referred like preteen boys and they will
watch Megan Fox
so yeah Megan Fox I don't really know
I'm not like super excited about the
movie anymore it looks like it'll be a
fun summer action movie teenager news
journal go watch it or don't I don't
care I probably won't see it sorry guys
unless Brian makes me cuz if he buys you
the ticket I guess I'll go see it if
it's free you know he also bought us
popcorn when we saw x-men so I do love
popcorn but if you liked what I did here
subscribe to the channel click the
button and then we're gonna play Ryan's
favorite game so click the button over
here and click the button over here
and here in here let's see if he's
actually gonna do this I guess I have my
own YouTube channel I have six
subscribers even though I don't have any
videos yet but I did just post my first
video this morning so if you like what I
did here subscribe to my channel and
Ryan's gonna put a button for it right
here right this is a button for my
channel I think I don't know what's
happening
so do that while I do some really cool
awesome shoutouts
oh I'm shining out whoever I want to
show it out I'd like to shout this video
out to my cool friend Ryan Ryan he's
making this video I don't know he didn't
give me a list of people shout out he's
a slick shot everyone this is a shout
out to all the subscribers thanks for
the support guys